no don't do this to me here babies my
little puppy
okay so I'm Miley and I'm chillin with
BuzzFeed but more importantly not more
importantly but kind of I'm playing with
puppies there's the only way I do
interviews these days I tell my writer I
require puppies you love me okay we're
gonna be answering some fan questions
you can smell my that ya eat my ring
show you my ring
great okay what does being younger now
mean to you well just like these puppies
all I want to do is be with my family
and be with my friends and know it's
important which is being happy you want
to pick all the sessions with you
okay I can't this is the worst way to
have me do an interview I'm not leaving
without this angel okay next what chunk
from younger now is the most special to
you Malibu was the first song that I
wrote on this record so it's extra
special to me I'm my angel what has been
the most inspiring to you during the
creation of your new album I wrote my
new album at my studio rainbow land
which is also a song that I sing with
Dolly Parton and so there's being around
all the colors always really inspired me
okay what advice would you give your 14
year old self never google yourself I
read one time that if you trust and love
your decisions the less that you care
what other people think about them so be
happy with your decisions are your songs
for the younger now put in a specific
order to tell the story or just put on
the album in order for no specific
reason everything on the record has a
reason in younger now the song there's
the sound of the river that's at my
house
Malibu that's where my house is and then
rainbow land of a studio at my house so
it's kind of like introducing people to
where I made the record and was inspired
by where I am and inspired by rainbow
man you guys are turned for the max how
did it feel the thing that's on the
climb for the first time 10 years as
good as it feels holding my little angel
your name is angel and into angel that
was my grandma's dog's name when there
was a tragedy in Vegas it was so amazing
to be able to sing that song and be able
to make it current for whatever one
needed to hear that there's always gonna
be another mountain another struggle but
it's all about the climbs that's my
shirt okay you're getting my titties out
come on I have to keep the angel so do
you think what land will be so bad I
have any advice for young women who feel
repressed when it comes to their idea my
advice would be surround yourself with
friends who things like you but also
make sure you expose yourself to
different types of people but keep
people around you that always lifts you
up and support you you're my little
friend you're my best friend so don't
tell my other seven dogs you know your
name is turn because you are turn if you
could talk to your animals and have them
understand you what would you want to
tell them I would hope that all of them
know how much that I love them but I
have no doubt in my mind that they do
because I treat them better than my own
family members what's the sweetest thing
a fan has ever done for you I think my
fans allowing me to have happy hippie in
the way that they've really supported it
and opened up about themselves found my
charity angel demon if you weren't a
singer what would you be doing this 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 your
name is hectic your name is church and
your name is Alayne Joe this was my
favorite interview I've ever done ever
in the history of my life for obvious
puppy reasons make sure you adopt these
puppies they're all available except
maybe this one from the North Shore
Animal League America
look at you come on send helios a
million please please just a little one
that's chilling
[Music]